this week's classic interview is one
that is very relevant given Donald
Trump's presence in next week's
Republican and Democratic final faceoff
in the presidential election in 2014 I
interviewed Scott Kaufman and the topic
was do women actually want the alpha
male it was an interview that at the
time generated quite a bit of
controversy I got a lot of emails from
people saying David this is basically
just making beta males feel better by
questioning whether women really want
the alpha male and it's so interesting
now in the context of the Trump Clinton
election because of the conversations
around Trump and sexual assault and him
being defended as hey this is just alpha
male behavior and there's a lot of beta
males that don't like it and bla bla bla
bla bla so let's go back to August of
2014 when I spoke to Scott Kaufman about
this I'm going to be thinking about this
in the context of the election that is
now just a few days away I'm joined
today by Scott Kaufman he is scientific
director of the imagination Institute
also a researcher at the positive
psychology Center at the University of
Pennsylvania Scott I came across your
work you wrote an article a very very
interesting article about the idea of
the Alpha versus the beta male so for
people who may not be familiar with that
dichotomy let's start there what is the
idea around the alpha and beta male well
there's a lot of discussion on the
internet about this distinction between
the Alpha and the beta and the Alpha is
usually described as the really dominant
male who and the dominance is usually
associate with aggression with putting
down others with Machiavellianism and
using strategy to manipulate others and
kind of getting your way bait by being
the top dog through that's sort of
aggression and the beta male is usually
depicted as submissive and weak and and
sensitive and this kind of portrayal of
this alpha beta this distinction leads
out all of these shades of grey which is
actually what is attractive to women and
what is actually the most likely to
reach the high high status social status
hierarchy so understanding of course
that
talking about this in male-female
relationships and that it is certainly a
kind of heteronormative way to look at
this for the purposes of your article
and the research we're looking at that's
what it looked at so we're not ignoring
that but we're kind of working within
that framework what does research
actually show when it is explored what
when when the kind of preference towards
these two alpha and beta males are
explored what does research actually
tell us there are different forms of
aggression you find that in the animal
kingdom you find that we're also animals
right so you find that amongst humans
that there's an Agora sort of kind of
dominance where you are you're stating
clearly what you want and your values
and your maybe dominating competition
among other fellow males you know it
could be a mating company the mating is
a competition as well right so
dominating that countries are dominant
likes in sports but it's very clear that
your while you're being assertive you're
not using they're directing that
aggression or sort of towards the woman
in a way that might be physically
dangerous to the woman and there's
another kind of assertive dominance
which is the kind of dominance that
really does involve this kind of
aggression and this the stereotypical
testosterone where you know your your
way is the right way and when you when
you actually look at the science of what
women find immensely attractive it's
it's at that form of assertive that form
of dominance that I was talking about
that is assertiveness combined
specifically with pro-sociality or the
kindness the potential for kindness so a
really potent combination is that
combination of assertiveness where you
not aggression but as the service with
this potential for for pro-sociality or
and the potential for doing something
that's very culturally valued in this
world doing producing something or
having a skill set that a lot of people
will recognize is is is great and is
very valuable this combination is what
is immensely attractive to women it's
very very interesting because if you
look at society and particularly through
the lens of of
Media right there's a very different
message that is being sent to many males
by many areas of our of our kind of
media and culture framework in terms of
what is expected right in terms of
making women attracted to you and
advertisers and big companies are aware
of this and they've actually used this
to their advantage as well if you look
at cigarette advertising decade in
decades past this idea of the aggressive
caricature of the so-called alpha male
is really an image that's been
reinforced quite a bit for men hasn't it
it hasn't I think it's unfortunate
because you have a lot of young men who
may not have a lot of success with women
thinking that they need to adopt some of
these traits in order to get women and
they're actually pushing women further
away and it's creating a very dangerous
cycle for both the male and the female
unhealthy cycle as well as just not
productive it's not getting them closer
to their goals if you want to get closer
to your meeting goals what what what
what you know I would I would look at
this actual literature on what is
actually attractive to women really
trying to get something that's
culturally valuable and then be your
authentic self you know in a sense I
know that phrases thrown around a lot be
your authentic self and what I mean by
that is get to really get in touch with
what your your sexual attraction
uniquely is going to be because women
find lots of different things sexually
attractive they and they find that when
when you are really cultivating that's
really coming from a deep within aspect
of yourself you're expressing yourself
in a deep way that is culturally
valuable that that in itself is is very
sexually powerful to women women are not
necessarily looking for one prototype
and there are obviously lots of women
differ and what they're looking for but
an overarching theme among women as they
find this sort of when it when it when
it seems to be authentically coming from
within that is what it's actually
attractive and that that may be why
there's this confound here you know
people say oh bad boy bizarre or
sexually attractive well maybe what's
going what I think those research
suggests is that bad boys bad boys in
the sense that they say whatever they
want
curse you know they they're their
rebellious those traits are sexy
attractive because that person is is not
is being themselves right if you're a
genuinely a bad boy be a bad boy but if
you're generally not a bad boy don't try
to be a bad boy because that won't be
attractive
Scott and your research how early in in
men's lives would you say this
stereotype or caricature of the
aggressive alpha male starts to show up
and be kind of pushed on young man I
mean can do you have a sense of how
early in life we can see that
well we're steeped we're steeped in this
culture and we're in very early in life
you you realize that there's this
hierarchy in school which is an
artificial hierarchy then is not like
the real world but there's a hierarchy
where the bully is on tops and we get
this impression that that that and
usually the the bully or the you know
they do get sexual success in high
school and and think of that but you
need what a lot of young and men really
need to realize is that out there in the
real world on the stage of life we get
much more freedom to pursue and dominate
our fields not dominate people in a in a
hubristic way which is not sexually
attractive for women in a way that
involves hubris and narcissism and
aggression and insecurity because at the
root of that is insecurity and women
don't find insecurity I try to they may
be a bit a full women in the short term
but very quickly research shows the
relationships after the nine-month mark
don't last with the narcissist or would
that that sort of bully insecurity type
of personality really for long lasting
in the real world is cold thing lots of
other things but unfortunately your
point is very well taken unfortunately
it's very easy for the guy for the young
male to not realize that because of the
way our the hierarchical structure the
artificial microcosm of Education is set
up I'm I'm interested in that this idea
that in school the bully actually does
do well-defined a few different ways
does it stand to reason that when humans
were still I won't say an X number of
years ago but when humans were closer to
being in a state of nature that the
modern day bully
may actually also have been the one that
did the best at that time in other words
is there some genetic element here
possibly there are different paths to
social status and in this article I
wrote the myth of the alpha male I
reviewed the evolutionary literature
even the evolutionary literature
suggests that even if you go far back in
our lineage the assertive but not
aggressively dominant male did just as
well in the social status hungry
actually did better in a wider range of
situations hmm so the bully is very
successful in a narrower range of
situations so if you're in jail if
you're in a jail you know obviously the
stereotypical alpha male you know who
works out a lot and it is physically
dominant is going to to be the alpha
male in that environment but what I
wanted to make the point in this article
is that over a wider range of
environments in the in the real world
it is this what I would literally calls
the prestigious male not the dominant
male
it's the prestigious man who combines
assertiveness with kindness with a
culture value and skill that is more
successful in life across all domains
not just a meeting domain but also in
professionally and personally very
nourishing stuff we've been speaking
with Scott Kaufman he is scientific
director of the imagination Institute
also a researcher in the positive
psychology Center at the University of
Pennsylvania really interesting stuff
Scott thanks for joining us thanks ed
while chatting about this topic